in the G protein coupled receptors  signaling the receptor is a seven  transmembrane domain containing protein  and the key player is the G protein  which is trimetic in nature having alpha  beta and gamma subunits when the ligand  binds the primary G protein exchange GTP  in place of GDP and gets activated then  it can activate enzyme like adenylate  cyclase which allows the production of  cyclic amp cyclic amp is produced from  ATP then cyclic amp can bind to specific  kinases such as protein kinase a protein  kinase a catalytic subunit dissociates  and moves to the nucleus where it  activates gene expression and thereby  the cellular response of this signaling  can be understood watch the full video  to know more